[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est à futur en seine qui
est le salon de tout ce qui est
technologies du futur
toutes les technologies de demain et
tout ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver aussi
bien au niveau du e-commerce au niveau
du retail que ce soit aussi au niveau de
la santé au niveau du jeu vidéo et la gt
rencontrer l'équipe de black note qui
est le netflix du jeu vidéo on va
pouvoir jouer à plein de jeux vidéos
directement sur plein de device
connectés et ça ça va être vraiment bien
je vous présente cette équipe
blacklock c'est une plateforme de cloud
gaming au cloud gaming c'est quoi c'est
un système de distribution de jeux vidéo
on est en train de construire un
catalogue de jeux qu'on va vous
permettre de auquel voulaient pouvoir
accéder depuis n'importe quel de votre
écran ce soit une télévision connectée
une box opérateur mais un smartphone ou
une tablette ou voir même un pc donc là
ce que deviendra cotherix et tout le
tour de magie il est base c'est que l'on
ne verra pas tout ça c'est qu'on sera
sur n'importe quel écran on clique rat
et le jeu sans avoir besoin de
télécharger sans avoir besoin de
l'installer sur un mois avant de
maintenir cette installation montant des
mises à jour des machins et se lancera
instantanément donc il faut imaginer un
service un petit peu comme un netflix ou
à spotify ou qu'on clique sajoo et sa
appliquée aux jeux vidéo avec donc tous
les divas les interactions des manettes
les télécommandes de télé
le téléphone pour les téléphones l'amour
au clavier souris
les serveurs sont chez nous sont
hébergés chez opérateurs cloud et la
puissance pour vous pour le joueur c'est
juste quelque chose qui est capable de
décoder influent un flux vidéo et de
gérer une manette une manette de jeu ou
un périphérique d'entrée
donc en fait c'est quasiment tout près
n'importe quel périphérique aujourd'hui
est capable de jouer à des jeux
éventuellement gourmand puisque la
puissance de calcul et d'un schéma donc
comme le moindre même des vieux
ordinateurs pour jouer aux jeux les plus
récents dans l'or dans leurs réglages
les plus avancés puisque évidemment le
la computation est faite par quelqu'un
d'autre que samassa science de la
conduite avec ses doigts la culture
aujourd'hui on attend un peu près 150
jeux sur lesquels on a les acquis les
droits de distribution et d'exploitation
et c'est vraiment un un catalogue qui va
augmenter avec des gros titres des
petites puces indépendance c'est un peu
ta spécialité oscars mais on veut
construire un catalogue qui soit avec du
contenu pour tout le monde du contenu
très connu du contenu moins connus du
contenu original pour plus rapide
contenu longue tant parler extrêmement
bien je suis très admiratif le l'idée
c'est de ce canton dit avoir tous les
concours c'est aussi pour les âges donc
avoir des contenus pour plutôt les
enfants ont des contenus vraiment pour
les adultes
pas forcément dans la violence à terme
et dans les thèmes qu'on peut évoquer
qu'on a le droit d'évoquer avec le jeu
vidéo et il faut savoir qu'il ya à peu
près 150 go qui sort tous les jours que
des grandes plateformes de jeux vidéo
est long de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de jeux
nous en l'occurrence on veut faire le
trip là dedans pour nos utilisateurs
donc on va pas avoir tous les jeux du
monde on va voir les meilleurs jeux dans
chacune des catégories pour tous les
âges pour tous les moments de jeu aussi
et puis pour les moments de vie parce
que dans la façon dont on a fabriqué
notre catalogue
vous allez avoir par exemple sur caen
avant de lancer un jeu vous saurez
combien de temps dure une partie en
moyenne combien de temps il faut pour
finir le jeu en entier et donc vous
serez capable de vous engager en disant
bon ok s'il faut que j'aille faire mes
courses que tu sais quand je suis un
adulte que j'ai des enfants etc
je veux je veux pouvoir m'engager dans
un truc dont je connais la durée et donc
on fabrique aussi notre catalogue comme
ça parce que l'abonnement aujourd'hui en
early access à 15 euros par mois et lyon
devrait le maintien qui peut à 18 20
euros
en moi dans la phrase
la vraie phase commerciale ou publique
tout âge avec évidemment pour les
parents des systèmes de contrôle pour
que leur enfant je sois pas trop soit
dans des plages horaires autorisés soit
des restrictions d'âge autorisé soit
même à des thèmes ou exclure des jeux
particulier de votre téléphone peut
servir à deux choses donc soit à jouer
avec des jeux effectivement vous allez
jouer vraiment sur votre smartphone soit
des quadras contrôle et soient
contrôlées un jeu qui va s'exécuter sur
un autre périphérique typiquement c'est
le cas si vous jouez sur votre
télévision vous allez pouvoir utiliser
surface tactile de votre téléphone pour
émuler la souris on court on pourra voir
les capteurs de position pour interagir
avec le jeu un petit peu à la façon de
la wiimote de ce genre de périphérique
donc il faut imaginer le téléphone écran
le téléphone mallette la samare chèque
de la 4g simplement ça va le wifi aussi
il vous faut partout vous pouvez re soir
n'est depuis que vous pourrez recevoir
nos jeux enfin jouer et interagir avec
nos jeux le débit nominal on va dire il
faut pour avoir un jeu avec une belle
qualité d'image il faut avoir au moins
six milliards 5,6 megabit par seconde ce
qui est tout à fait accessible
aujourd'hui même avec un bon adsl et si
vous n'avez plus c'est mieux si vous
avez moins ça pourrait marcher aussi
mais vous aurez peut-être pas des jeux
aussi aussi beau soutenir tout notamment
si vous jouez sur des très grands écrans
il faut imaginer que le lag se
transforme c'est à dire que on imagine
aussi beaucoup aujourd'hui surtout chez
les gens qui jouent beaucoup jeu vidéo
que le lag c'est l'image qui saccade qui
va bien et c'est le lag de black note si
vous avez une mauvaise connexion ce sera
plutôt du lac comme dans netflix de
youtube la qualité des sens le service
et en les re ly access depuis hier donc
sert que vous allez pouvoir aller sur
notre site web blake 9 points comme vous
enregistrer répondre à un petit
questionnaire et puis on va ouvrir des
accès
au fur et à mesure dans les jours qui
viennent et puis pendant cet été
de plus en plus est le vrai service en
version commerciale ouverte tout le
monde ce serait pour la fin de l'année
au final dac note c'est vraiment une
solution de futurs maintenant reste à
voir effectivement les jeux vidéos qui
vont être proposées les différentes
licences pour voir s'ils auront des
licences qui seront assez forte pour
pour attirer plein plein de joueurs et
plein de consommateurs en tout cas j'ai
pu voir la solution j'ai pu la voir
tourner et elle est vraiment super sympa
super agréable et on doit dire
qu'effectivement ça va continuer à
démocratiser de jeux vidéo et faire
qu'elle plus en plus de personnes qui
viennent à jouer on connaissait déjà les
petits jeux les petites applis qu'on
pouvait télécharger mais là vous avez un
catalogue complet avec des jeux qui ont
l'air d'être vraiment super et ça vous
pourrez y jouer partout quel que soit
votre diva que ce soit chez vous ça va
encore plus loin
on va pouvoir jouer encore plus dès
qu'on a un petit moment contrôler son
taux de jeu et ça c'est vraiment bien
que ce soit pour des adultes ou aussi
pour des enfants tout en sachant que
comme il le disait des parents au
pouvoir contrôler donc black note c'est
une solution qui sortira en fin d'année
mais qui pour l'instant en tout cas à
l'air d'être vraiment prometteuse
merci d'avoir regardé les vidéos dites
moi ce que vous en pensez mais témoin
tout en commentaire est ce que vous
trouvez que cette solution a l'air
intéressante est ce que vous seriez prêt
vous à souscrire un abonnement
et puis à jouer à ces jeux donc on se
marre tout en remarquant commentaires
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
et puis on se donne rendez vous très
bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos ciao
[Musique]